They jumped her Catalan,
their goods,
which they had gotten in the land
of Canaan and came into Egypt,
Jacob and all his seed with them.
And he sent Judah before month
Joseph to direct his face under gosh.
And,
and they came into the land of Goshen and
Joseph Made ready his chariot and went
to meet Israel,
his father,
and presented himself to them and fell
on his neck and wept on his neck a good
while.
And Israel said,
I can now die because I've seen your
face because you're still alive.
And Pharaoh spake unto Joseph saying that
father and thy brethren are coming to
the,
and the land of Egypt is before
the and the best of the land.
Your father and brothers can dwell in
the land of Gosh and let them dwell.
And if they're now no any
men of activity among them,
then make them rulers over my cattle.
It gives them a job.
And Joseph brought in Jacob,
his father and said,
and before Pharaoh and
Jacob Blessed Pharaoh.
That's a very interesting little turn
of events because you'd expect the
opposite under those circumstances.
So
it appears that Jacob was a man of
relatively great self possession.
Cause that's not an,
you wouldn't bless Queen Elizabeth in
all likelihood as you had a lot of gall.
And Pharaoh said unto Jacob,
how old are you?
And Jacob said,
I'm 130 years,
few and evil have been the days of the
years of my life and I've not attained
unto the days of the years of my,
of my,
of the life of my fathers and
the days of their pilgrimage.
And Jacob Blessed Pharaoh and went out
from before Pharaoh and Israel dwelt in
the land of Egypt,
in the country of Gosh,
and,
and grew and multiplied exceedingly.
And Jacob lived in the land of Egypt,
17 years.
So the whole age of Jacob was 147 years.
And the time drew nigh
that Israel must die.
And he called his son.
Joseph had said unto him,
if I have now found grace in thy sight,
put,
I pray thee thy hand under my thigh
and deal kindly and truly with me,
bury me.
Not,
I pray thee in Egypt,
but I will lie with my fathers now shall
carry me out of Egypt and burry me and
they're burying place.
And Joseph said,
I will do as you've said.
And it came to pass after these
things that one told Joseph,
behold I father is sick.
And he took with him his two sons,
Madison FM and one told Jacob and said,
behold thy son.
And one told Jacob and said,
behold thy son,
Joseph Cometh unto Thee and Israel
strength in himself and sat upon the bed.
And Israel said unto Joseph,
I had not thought to see your face and
low God has also showed me your children.
And Joseph brought them out from between
his knees and out himself with his face
to the earth.
And Joseph took them both and for him
in his right hand towards Israel's
lefthand and Madison,
his lefthand toward Israel's right
hand and brought them near unto him.
And Israel stretched out his right hand
and laid it upon firms head who was the
younger and his left hand upon Madison's
head guiding his hands purposefully for
Madison was the first board.
And when Joseph saw that his father laid
his right hand on the head of the frame
and displeased him and he held up as far
as hand to remove it from informs head
onto [inaudible] head.
And Joseph said unto his father,
not,
not.
So my father for this is the first board
put the right hand upon his head head
and his father refused and said,
I know what my son,
I know it.
He shall also become a people
and he shall also be great,
but truly his younger brother shall be
greater than he and his seed shall become
a multitude of nations.
Another repeat of the same
thing that happens continually.
It's is when,
when God wants to
intervene in human affairs,
what he does is invert tradition.
It's something like that.
And so that's a sign that that there's
something new and special going on and
that gives precedents to the younger
child rather than the older child
precedents to what is new
rather than what's traditional.
Of course,
sometimes that's necessary because
tradition is insufficient and sometimes
something new has to come into
being in order to update it.
And Jacob called together
his sons and said,
gathered together so that I can tell you
that which shall be follow you in the
last days.
Gather yourself together and here you
sons of Jacob and hearken unto Israel,
your father,
Ruben.
I'm not going to go through
all 12 of these Reuben,
thou art,
my firstborn,
my might,
and the beginning of my strength,
the Excellency of Dignity
and the Excellency of power.
Now
the story's quite interesting here because
Jacob Blesses Joseph's sons before he
blesses it's old science.
And so what he's doing is placing the
rights of the first born into the sons of
his favorite son,
and then he goes to his sons.
And so that has implications for the
way the biblical stories laid themselves
out from thence forward
the excellence of dignity
in the Excellency of power,
unstable as water.
Thou shalt not excel because
that went up to thy father's bed,
then defiled it.
He went up to my couch.
You may remember that Ruben
slept with his fathers,
cucumber,
concubine,
Simeon and Levi are brethren.
Instruments of cruelty
are in their habitations.
That painting there.
What happened with Simeon and Levi was
that somebody lay with their sister Dinah
and then offered to marry her and then
had and then he came circumcised because
that was part of the deal and then how
to older men circumcised and then Simeon
and Levi went in when they were recovering
and killed them all and then Jacob
and all his people had to leave because
all that irritated their relatives.
So
see me,
Simeon and Levi are brethren
the instruments of cruelty
or in their habitations.
All my soul come out into their
secret unto their assembly,
mine on or be not thou United for in
their anger they slew a man and in their
self self will they dig down a wall,
curse be their anger.
For it was fierce and their
route for it was cruel.
I will divide them in Jacob
and scattered them in Israel,
Judah,
thou art.
He who my brother and shall praise I hand
shall be in the neck of dynamics that
I father's children shall bow down before
the Judah is alliance welp from the
prey.
My son though art gone up,
he stooped down.
He couched as a lion and as an
old lion who shall rose him up.
The sceptre shall not depart from Judah,
nor a law giver from between his feet
until Shiloh camp and unto him shall the
gathering of the people be.
Joseph is a fruitful bough,
even a fruitful bough by a well
whose branches run over the wall.
The archers have sorely grieved
him and shot at him and hated him,
but his bow abode in strength and the
arms of his hands were made strong by the
hands of the mighty God of Jacob.
For then since the shepherd,
the stone of Israel,
even by the god of my father,
who she'll help the and by the Almighty
who shall bless thee with the blessings
of heavens above blessings of the deep
that Liat under blessings of the beasts,
breasts,
and of the womb.
The blessings of thy father have prevailed
above the blessings of my progenitors
unto the utmost bound of
the everlasting hills.
They shall be on the head of Joseph and
on the crown of the head of him that was
separate from his brother and all
these are the 12 tribes of Israel,
and this is it.
That they're farther spake
unto them and blessed them.
Everyone according to his blessing,
he blessed them.